uh what can I say the biggest piece of
anime like the biggest event in anime
has just dropped guys the biggest piece
of anime the biggest piece of anime
definitely definitely the anime of all
time definitely in the history of anime
bigger than Dragon Ball bigger than one
piece bigger than the Bible too you want
do you want to reiterate for people who
perhaps don't know what the thumbnail is
they've been living under a rock yeah so
uh Attack on Titan just finished airing
this week so we thought we'd do our
topical episode because uh we've all
seen Attack on Titan right right right
surely I finished it I finished it I
finished it did you actually yeah I
finished it oh okay why you why are you
looking at it like [__] I thought you on
my side I watch I I watched it oh okay I
didn't
wow okay you had you had one job we
start you one job I just don't care
about Attack on Titan anymore okay
that's just like okay it might be
because like how far did you get I got
up to the oh God the naming convention
uh the final season part one okay wait
is that the correct ter I don't even
know what the [__] doesn't the final
season of three parts final season is
three parts there in the third part
there's two parts oh yeah okay so that
means I got up to yeah part two I
haven't watched the I haven't watched
the third season part one or two just
the the two hour long
yeah I got up to there so you you
basically just got everything up to the
ending bit so you've only got like two
and a half hours of Attack on Titan left
to go and you don't have any interest in
finishing it I'll get to it eventually I
guess but I'm not in a rush all right so
I'm going to say like normally we have
like a spoiler warning or something but
we you know uh normally sorry normally
we try to avoid spoilers but I'm pretty
sure we can't discuss all of this
without spoiling are we discussing it I
haven't even seen it yeah if we if we do
spoilers people are going to skip right
in the start of the episode so we we'll
save a little bit of the spoilers for
sing the Met game yeah because if we's
going to YouTube's going to hate this
episode if we do that yeah don't worry
we'll give you guys a warning when we
get when we actually get to the ending
but yeah I feel like I watched it I did
watch the ending just out of like
commitment I'm like well I'm like I'm
this far in I should just finish well I
mean what it was a 10e run right yeah
I've been watching it since it came out
Dam 2013 it like it really was this it
really is like an end of an era cuz
I think Attack on Titan really kind of
grew up with the medium it was kind of
like that first big push of like oh
anime has like gone from this little
niche thing to something that can kind
of like meet mainstream culture and it
was kind of like it it kind of to me as
how can Titan signified that show from
anime growing from something that was a
bit more Niche to something that now is
even like arguably mainstream you know
totally I think it's very and even
people who don't like anime are like I
know Attack on Titan yeah yeah exactly I
remember cuz I I think I got into anime
in like 2012 2011 and then Attack on
Titan was the one that was really big
yeah and before that I actually didn't
watch Subs I was like know I'm a d only
guy I don't want to read [__] but attack
of Titan uh didn't have a dub for a very
long time and I was like well [__] I got
to I got to watch the show when the dub
came out it was an amazing
dub uh I think the dub was actually
pretty it I think the dub is i' I've
I've watched both the sub and the dub uh
and the dub was actually for the most
part pretty damn good uh I mean when I
think of the dub I think of the arm and
scream yeah well that was kind of iconic
ionic I don't remember this one you
don't remember it a big meme it was a
huge meme of the dub Arman scream of
like I think it was like episode two or
three of season one when like the first
big like I guess remember uh twist
happens right with Aaron um and Armen
does this scream and in the Japanese one
it's very powerful and then the dub came
out and it got mean to absolute [__]
pull P pull it up I got to hear this I'm
surprised you haven't seen this just
almond scream dub just almond scream dub
almond scream dub I mean like well what
we're pulling this up um yeah I mean
I've watched all of the dub except for
the final season of the dub yeah yeah
well you watched a lot of it I've
rewatched Al Tian quite quite a few
times well it's uh is it Matthew Mercy
plays Levi uh I can't remember I mean it
makes sense I feel like it is I feel it
works if it's not him go go go to the
end go to the end just the scream yeah
yeah yeah right there yeah right there
so it's this
part that scream was the
meme
okay it sounds like a D2 very Crush
Bandicoot bit of
nature I don't think it was necessarily
bad it was just like it's very funny out
of contest yeah yeah yeah I'm also
biased I I think cuz J Michael Tatum is
uh he's win I think he crushes it no I
think win I think I think wiwin was
actually my favorite performance from
the dub uh Irwin completely I didn't
know it was J marum makes a lot of sense
I think my biggest problem with the dub
where I would recommend the sub over the
dub uh was unfortunately B Bryce papen
Brook's uh portrayal of Aaron uh because
I I think he does really good in season
one but there are some kind of like
moments uh a lot as the series goes on
yeah yeah there were there was some
moments where I think I think he's like
a really talented voice actor but I
think he got casted at a time where he
was getting casted as K yeah he was K
has like every edgy kind of like
protagonist um and so I I I think you
know he does really really good in other
roles and there was like a certain few
moments where I just didn't think he hit
the same like emotional beats as other
people could have done if they had got
been casted as Aaron I think the scene
that really sold it for me was um Erin's
breakdown in the end of season 2 where I
remember watching it and I was just like
o this is this is not hitting that same
emotional beat that the original voice
actor did who's the original voice actor
againi Kaji Yuki did I mean kaj Yuki is
go a god kaj Yuki is a God but uh yeah
it was uh it was something that I didn't
think matched up to the original and um
it was also a bit weird seeing I saw a
little bit of the beginning of season 4
or like the final season and he still
had a very similar voice and I heard
he's improved that for like later parts
of the final season but it just it just
felt very off cuz uh uh so I would
actually genuinely I've watched both and
I would genuinely recommend the sub over
the dub this isn't like a stay
the dub was bad sure yeah but then if
you if for some reason youever say like
I prefer the dub people would be like
just you can't appreciate the
Japanese you're weeing up you talking
about like hey I I'm fluent in this
language and I think it sounds good in
this language sometimes like yeah happy
to admit when it sounds it's personal
preference at the end of the day there's
no right or wrong yeah I mean I I would
say Owen uh I didn't know it was J Mark
or Tatum but I actually prefer just
slightly just slightly because both are
like such goated performances but holy
[__] hearing his speech uh in English I
was like God this this hit different man
I'm I'm ready to go to war right
now yeah I mean I'm biased Michael's
such a great actor in general so it's I
mean I just like being around him
because he's always the way he talks
about acting he like man I wish wish my
brain just worked like this about acting
like there's just such a passion for it
well he's our boy you know like we're
going to be biased towards our boys yeah
anyway uh but I remember the dub didn't
come out for ages so I got into the sub
cuz I wanted to watch it and everyone
was talking about it and it was uh I the
dude the fandom back then was so
interesting for Attack on Titan uh is it
all interesting now but it was well it
is but it was just so like it was so
bizarre how uh it was at a time where I
felt that uh back then in the English
fandom I feel like manga readers were
like a huge minority oh yeah like oh for
sure no one Read Manga much and and when
you were interact with people they'd
only ever it used a given that you were
like oh you just you watched only the
I met people who had read the mang very
very small vocal minority I think
whereas like it is still I think it is
today but I think that amount has just
increased a lot more because of people
just constantly being like the manga is
better the manger is better there a
bunch of like fan stuff when I was way
younger about like of people I guess
doing their own audio Productions of
their own madeup stories in the universe
and I was like okay
yeah I'll do [__] it uh so I did like
that but uh yeah uh on Titan otherwise
uh I said this earlier and this is why
you wanted to talk about it because you
got annoyed by my comments I felt like
uh although I I I wanted to finish this
journey because I felt like it it' kind
of been my entire adult life was Attack
on Titan I was like I should I should I
should watch it uh the final season part
two I was kind of
bored I I
I I can't
believe I I can't I like genuinely
genuinely can we all agree that the the
gnomen clature I want to use that word
for so long of the the nomenclature of
the the attack on Titan series what does
that mean oh well god wow son go on go
on
intellectual the the the groups the
naming uh like how you name a certain
group of things and no man is in name
yeah okay and the way they've named the
series [__] awful absolutely the
worst naming job in history of show I
think that was my problem with
especially the final season is that I
the naming convention is just so
confusing take away from the series yeah
I think it has as well to be honest and
I think that's why I just kind of lost
interest cuz I'm like they're not
[__] taking this is not a take I'm
here right now this is this is not this
is no bearing on the show can I just say
this in general it is absolutely [__]
confusing to try and keep track on on
certain places to watch this like wait
which [__] one am I on again why do
they all have different you bad when
like my Photoshop files are named better
you know like it's it's the Xbox series
1 x looks like a better naming system as
opposed to this [__] say this is my
message to fate fans that say I over
complicate this [__] if these guys can't
follow along with conventions in attack
on titon
[__] the exact same reason why a lot
of people struggle to get into fate as
well because they look at a title and
they go I I don't know where this is
canonically speaking so I'm not even
going to bother starting to do it yeah I
mean this and attack on time just
fumbled the bag at the end in my opinion
to the point where like I can't take
this [__] seriously anymore these naming
conventions are garbage that has no
[__] bearing on the it has no bearing
on the show but personally I was like
that [__] is annoying as [__] it's
annoying as [__] there's nothing to do
like this is like the you know I thought
you were coming out with the big gun I
will I will but we just we have to
recognize that they [__] up with this
show for some godamn reason you could be
the biggest Attack on Titan fan and
every Attack on Titan fan will agree the
naming convention is ass it's not
horrendous it's not optimized but let's
talk to like Kingdom Hearts fans for
like a second here and just another
reason another reason why people don't
take that [__] seriously because they
look at these Nami conventions and they
same with [__] monari any any series
that has the most like nonsecular and
non you know sequential naming system
people from the outside look at it and
go what the [__] is this how am I
supposed to get into this I will say
seeing that naming system slowly being
revealed and rolled out it did make me
kind of like lose confidence a bit in
the production I'm like I'm like how are
you guys fumbling this so badly like
like there is no goddamn reason why
there should be final season part one
part two part three that is that is
insane like what what like what actually
happened for this [__] there has to be a
[__] Look up the word final in the
has to have been a [__] up in a way that
makes me like that made me nervous
initially when it was coming out because
I was like what is happening behind
theen well you know like I'm I'm I'm
going to defend it for now uh because I
believe that this is this is all based
on my pure feeling and speculation and
kind of like the vibe I get now being
you know you know having talked to a lot
of anime Studios and stuff like that I'm
sure same with you Joey which is I'm
sure they had a rough schedule to begin
with when when like mappa got signed on
and then they were like wait a minute we
actually want to take time to make this
[__] slap so the reason I think this
is because you look at the difference in
quality from Attack on Titan uh final
season part one to everything that came
out of came after it like there is a
such a huge jump in animation quality
it's like not even comparable and I
think that came came about because mappa
were like let's uh slow things down and
uh let's actually take time to make the
finale something that is worthy of the
lineage of Attack on Titan and you know
what if we get a bit of name [__] we
can meme about it all right but like
considering the final product we got I
think it was more than [__] worth the
wait you know I I like see I would have
been happy to wait even longer as long
as we all just got it in one cleanly
wrapped packaging like I I feel like the
fact that they released these final
seasons in so many different parts just
goes to show that like well okay but you
could have instead of just releasing it
you know and splitting it up into 15
different [__] parts and confusing
everybody why couldn't you have just
pushed everything back and just given it
to us all in one go we're okay with
waiting for you guys to you know work
your magic with the animation and the
production everything that's fine we've
already we've already been waiting seven
eight years at this point right for it
to finish so it's like why couldn't they
have just push that all back to the
point where okay here we go here is the
final season allinone nicely need you
know wrapped up bag I agree and you go
we also have recognized in the past that
for example Netflix kind of killed all
hype of Jojo the way that they released
it so you know the way you release a
series does matter as much as much as
like it shouldn't have any bearing on
the show you know a large part about
consuming media is the surrounding hype
are you into that are you like following
along with people like that that that
matters a lot to just consuming media in
general agree um and I I think that it
it you know it did it did kind of
detract a little bit from from the
series in a slight way nothing
meaningful of course but it did make it
did add an extra step where I felt that
like I felt like online generally people
just cared less about the show I
definitely agree um I think I don't know
what the creative decision between doing
the last finale in like two Mega hour an
hour and a half long episodes I they had
there's enough material there for a
season you know there's maybe not like a
full core 12 episode but definitely like
a strong 10 n episode like seon I am
really shocked that that the final two
parts weren't just a movie genuinely I I
can did I not call this years ago I
think we all had a feeling that they
might try it I was like they're going to
end it with like movie length episodes
and especially with them being
essentially one pretty long movie I'm
kind of surprised they didn't try and
release it theatrically
yeah you'd think they'd look at you know
or like Demon Slayer and take that as a
hint right it was like the worst parts
of Both Worlds you know you didn't get
the hype of releasing it as like a 49
episode season for like the hype to
build up but you also didn't get the
hype of having it be a theatrical
release which after you cut it in half
and separated over the course of a year
after watching it this could definitely
with like the with the quality they had
that they had this could have definitely
been a movie yeah you know um and they
there are some like moments love to
watch in the oh it it would have been
incredible this is the one when I'm like
yeah end it with the movie you CLE you
clearly want to end it off with the bang
if you don't want to split up into like
episodic like a final third season um so
just put it as a movie but for some
reason they released there two long
episodes that just dropped at random
intervals in the year and I'm like that
you you are doing everything you can to
like kill this and that's exactly what
it did for me it killed the hype for me
where where I got to the point where I'm
just like I'll get to it eventually I
guess but I'm not like frothing at the
mouth to finish it at the same time want
to finish it I do well yeah because
obviously I actually do because like you
know again like as Conor said like you
know we've all been sticking through
with this series for like 10 years right
and you know it's a great [__] show I
love the show but like it's just again
the release order and the way that they
fumbled the bag on that personally
speaking it just kind of lost the hype
for me and I'm just like I mean yeah
I'll get to it eventually I guess but
like I'm not I'm not like gagging to
like finish it